alle sind sich einig die Medizin der
Zukunft ist die personalisierte Medizin
jedem Patienten und jeder Patientin
individuell die bestmögliche Behandlung
geben dazu muss man aber eine Flut von
medizinischen Informationen für
Ärztinnen und Ärzte nutzbar machen die
gute Nachricht dafür gibt es schon heute
automatisierte Systeme die schlechte
Nachricht in der Praxis bleiben die
größtenteils ungenutzt woran das liegt
und wie eine Nachwuchsforschergruppe an
der TU Dresden das ändern möchte darum
geht es heute
künstliche Intelligenz in Zukunft dabei
helfen kann die Flut aus medizinischen
Daten zu sortieren und für eine Diagnose
einzusetzen darüber haben wir hier schon
mal berichtet das ist aber nur der
Anfang am Ende sollen die Ärztinnen und
Ärzte dieses Wissen ja auch nutzen
können dafür gibt es klinische
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme die
leider in der Praxis nur selten
akzeptiert werden aber bevor wir dazu
kommen müssen wir erst einmal verstehen
was sie überhaupt machen
[Musik]
wie der Name schon sagt sollen klinische
Entscheidungen zu Unterstützungssysteme
den Arzt oder die Ärztin dabei
unterstützen eine Entscheidung zu
treffen mit
entscheidungsunterstützungssystem kann
zwar auch ein Poster in der
Betriebsküche gemeint sein das erklärt
was in einem medizinischen Notfall zu
tun ist aber wir sprechen hier natürlich
von Computern von Big Data und von
künstlicher Intelligenz
computerbasierte klinische
entscheidungsunterstützungsliste okay
das tut mir langsam ein bisschen zu
umständlich ich sage jetzt einfach sie
die SS da steht für clinical decision
support system also die CDSs die
tatsächlich im Praxisalltag angekommen
sind weißen den Arzt z.B auch ungesunde
Blutwerte in einem Laborbericht hin ein
viel genutztes CDSs weist eine Ärztin
auf Wechselwirkungen zwischen
Medikamenten hin also z.B wenn ein
Patient bereits ein Medikament mit
ähnlicher Wirkung bekommt dann würde das
Programm warnen dass ich die Medikamente
gegenseitig verstärken denn das ist ja
möglicherweise schlecht für den
Patienten
auch im Schlaflabor von Dr Moritz Brandt
an der Uniklinik Dresden werden sie die
SS routinemäßig genutzt denn dort werden
von den Patienten viele Daten
gleichzeitig erhoben also EEG EKG und
vieles andere das sind am Ende 20 bis 30
verschiedene Signale die wir da erfassen
über als Zeitung von 8 Stunden also die
ganze Nacht das was wir jetzt gerade
sehen das ist ja zum Beispiel auch dann
ein CSS das ist was rot markiert genau
das ist eine Hilfe von der Software hat
hier eine Augenbewegung detektiert und
hat deswegen hier oben diese Markierung
gesetzt und ist auch korrekt das hilft
mir schon weil bei einfach zu
detektierenden Signalen die Software
schon insoweit entwickelt ist dass sie
mir da der hilft oder auch unterstützend
ist manche sind die SS sind also
durchaus auch heute schon hilfreich sie
sorgen dafür dass Ärztinnen und Ärzte
eher den passenden
Behandlungsempfehlungen folgen sie
verhindern unnötige Untersuchungen und
sie schlagen Medikamente mit weniger
Nebenwirkungen vor
aber das Problem ist dass solche Erfolge
die Ausnahme sind oder sogar einfach nur
das Ergebnis eines wissenschaftlichen
Experiments nicht die Realität in der
Praxis das hat uns Dr Britta siedlmeier
erklärt sie leitet in Dresden eine
Nachwuchsgruppe der Medizininformatik
Initiative auch da gibt es keine genauen
Zahlen weil man eben solche
flächendeckenden Befragungen
beispielsweise noch nicht durchgeführt
hat aber es gibt einzelne Studien wo
eben forschende gewisse Krankenhäuser
auch mal befragt haben und da kam raus
das von den Systemen die sich in der
Routine befinden nur ungefähr so um die
30% auch wirklich genutzt werden
sich nämlich oft überhaupt nicht in den
Praxisalltag ein z.B wenn die
Dateneingabe zu umständlich und die
Bedienung zu aufwendig ist oder sie
unterbrechen mit nervigen Pop-Ups den
Arbeitsfluss
oft ist es beispielsweise nämlich auch
gewünscht dass ich zwei Medikamente
gegenseitig verstärken die eben
beschriebene Warnung des CDSs wäre in
diesem Fall überflüssig und wenn die
meisten Warnungen eh nicht hilfreich
sind kriegt man sie irgendwann
vielleicht Routine mäßig ungelesen weg
und das ist natürlich nicht der Sinn der
Sache okay damit individualisierte
Medizin funktionieren kann müssen
Ärztinnen und Ärzte also sie die SSS
auch tatsächlich nutzen und das tun sie
nur wenn solche Designfehler vermieden
werden
[Musik]
diese Frage wollen dr siedlmeier und
ihre Nachwuchsforschergruppe in Dresden
beantworten ihr Ziel ist es den
Entwicklern von CDSs zu helfen
brauchbare Programme zu entwickeln ich
würde mehr wünschen dass das Thema
benutzerzentrierte Gestaltung mehr in
die Köpfe kommt man davon wegkommt zu
entwickeln ausgerichtet an der
technologischen Machbarkeit oft kennen
sich die Entwickler und EntwicklerInnen
nämlich sehr gut mit den Datenstrukturen
aus aber überhaupt nicht mit den
Arbeitsabläufen in der Praxis und so
entstehen oft Programme die eben tolle
Funktionen haben aber für die Ärztinnen
und Ärzte ungeeignet sind das Team von
Dr siedlmayr erforscht deshalb wie
Entscheidungen in der Klinik getroffen
werden und entwickelt daraus Modelle mit
Hilfe dieser Modelle sollen
programmiererinnen und Programmierer die
CDSs so gestalten können dass die
richtige Person zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
die richtige Entscheidungsunterstützung
präsentiert bekommt also möglichst viele
hilfreiche Warnungen und möglichst wenig
nerviger damit dass sie die SS
problemlos in die Arbeit eingebunden
wird braucht es natürlich auch eine
entsprechend intuitive
Benutzeroberfläche es gibt schon jede
Menge Forschung dazu wie man effektive
Benutzeroberflächen designen kann aber
das viele wissen kommt nicht unbedingt
bei den Entwicklern an deshalb sammelt
die Arbeitsgruppe das Wissen aus der
Mensch-Maschine interaktionsforschung
daraus entwickeln sie dann ein System
das dabei hilft die besten Design
Methoden für ein bestimmtes CDSs zu
finden
das ist ja dann quasi ein
entscheidungsunterstützungssystem für
die Entwicklung klinische
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme
und schließlich muss man als Arzt oder
Ärztin so einem klinischen
entscheidungsunterstützungssystem auch
vertrauen können wenn die Ärztin den
Vorschlag eines CDSs nicht
nachvollziehen kann wird sie die
Hilfestellung des Systems wahrscheinlich
ignorieren und doch wieder die ganze
Arbeit selbst machen ein gutes CDSs
erklärt deshalb nachvollziehbar wie es
zu seiner Entscheidung gekommen ist auch
dazu gibt es bereits Forschung die DR
Sedlmaier und ihr Team in eine Sammlung
von Blaupausen übersetzen an denen sich
die EntwicklerInnen und Entwickler dann
orientieren können um den direkten
Zugang zur Praxis zu haben arbeitet dr
seidelmeyers Team mit dem Schlaflabor
von Dr Brand zusammen ihn habt ihr schon
gerade kennengelernt wir waren hier vor
Ort haben hospitiert haben sich die
Abläufe angeschaut das ist auch ganz
interessant wenn dann die Klinik haben
mal wirklich verschriftlichen wie
eigentlich zum konkrete Ablauf im
Schlaflabor passiert und dann bei dieser
Erstellung fällt dann vielleicht erst
auf wie komplex ist eigentlich ist und
wo man über schnell vereinfachen könnte
insbesondere mit digitaler Hilfe so
sollen klinische
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme
entstehen die den Ärztinnen und Ärzten
ermöglichen jede Patientin und jeden
Patienten ganz individuell und optimal
zu behandeln
in der Zukunft sollen die CDSs mit
anderen Systemen verknüpft sein
Stichwort Digitalisierung und
elektronische Patientenakte dafür müssen
die CDSs auf der einen Seite eine immer
aktuelle Datenbasis bekommen mit
einheitlichen Standards auf der anderen
Seite müssen sie so konzipiert sein dass
sie die Arbeit des Fachpersonals auch
wirklich unterstützen und nicht
vielleicht sogar behindern
gleichzeitig soll der professionelle
Umgang mit den CSS Teil der ärztlichen
Ausbildung werden denn natürlich müssen
die Ärztinnen und Ärzte die
Behandlungsvorschläge der
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme auch
in Zukunft verstehen hinterfragen und
überprüfen können
okay aber wenn künstlichen Intelligenz
schon Behandlungsvorschläge macht könnte
sie dann irgendwann auch Ärzte ersetzen
daran glauben weder Doktor Brandt noch
dr Sedlmayr also es gibt einige
forschende im Bereich des maschinellen
Lernens die tatsächlich der Meinung sind
soll ich ein
entscheidungsunterstützungssystem könnte
uns Menschen ersetzen ich denke aber
eher nur in Teilbereichen und ich denke
auch was das System mit Sicherheit nicht
ersetzen wird ist diese persönliche ja
doch intime Beziehung zwischen Arzt und
Patient also vermutlich kein medizinisch
fotografisches Notfallprogramm
ist nicht in der Datei schade eigentlich
dieses Video ist in Zusammenarbeit mit
der Medizin Informatik Initiative des
Bundesministeriums für Bildung und
Forschung entstanden dort entwickeln
Hochschulen Unikliniken Krankenkassen
und IT-Unternehmen gemeinsam
intelligente IT-Lösungen mit deren Hilfe
werden Daten aus unterschiedlichsten
Quellen standardisiert und aus
verschiedenen Standorten
zusammengeführt um dann beispielsweise
durch CSS benutzt zu werden vielen Dank
an das Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung für die Unterstützung beim
Dreh dieses Videos und wenn ihr jetzt
sehen wollt wie ich meine Gesundheit von
einer KI analysiert haben lasse dann
klickt hier bis zum nächsten Mal bleibt
neugierig